film is a very important part of any
football program around the country you
get a certain amount of reps on the
field in practice you supplement those
reps by watching film from an endzone
view or a sidelined view the problem I
always had with watching film is the
vantage point you're sitting up in a box
basically it just looks totally
different virtual reality is kind of
something that puts you right there
virtual reality is using an immersive
display that basically right up in front
of your eyes so it not only is it
showing you something but it is tracking
the movement of your head and changing
the view in response to that and
whatever direction he moves his head in
he will see the rush coming from his
left or the rush coming from his right
you turn around and you can see the
running back
you see the line and you feel like
you're in the game and it's just a very
good simulation of an actual football
game and if you have immersive
360-degree sound that does more to
amplify the sense of presence your brain
really believes that you're in the space
that you're looking at - of VR headset
it's real video of real players who are
taking shots at you the puck then
becomes CG once it comes off their stick
so that's what enables you to interact
with it and you know block it or miss it
you're kind of sitting there like you're
gonna get out of this thing and you're
gonna be sweaty and you're gonna be
feeling like you just were out of the
ice triforce a company that uses virtual
reality technology to help train
football players instead of being on the
field you're in an immersive VR
environment Strieber was founded in the
Stanford football office I was doing
this as a project for my master's thesis
while I was coaching the goal number one
was to help Stanford football and then
always in the back of my mind I was
saying you know what I should really pay
attention to this thing because I really
like coaching but this is something that
could be pretty unique when players put
this thing on
we basically transport them into a 360
degrees scene of what they will actually
see on the field we do everything
ourselves during practice and then
afterwards we bring in all the footage
from the GoPros uploaded onto the
computers that they gave us four or five
hours later they send us back the final
product from there we just put in data
and it's ready to go the first time I
put the headset on was unbelievable
you're on the football field you're
standing behind Center you can hear my
voice talking at the snap of the ball
you see the defense moving and the play
gets started is surreal we're giving you
a first-person vantage point from where
you play that's very different from end
zone films sideline film drone can
nothing has been able to recreate until
now the actual viewpoint from where a
player plays from
there's also a training element I didn't
get the rep yesterday let me go get it
10 times or I got at once I need it
6 more times training a quarterback
through VR sounds a little bit like
science fiction it seems like something
from the far future but then you think
about how much of a quarterbacks job is
a visual it's pattern recognition kids
do this in Madden football they're
recognizing defenses and reacting to
them you think about a quarterback who
can now prepare and decipher defenses
more quickly than and they can today is
gonna force the defense to step up and
it's just gonna elevate the game and
become more compelling to watch the big
benefits of this kind of training is
nobody's tackling you nobody's hitting
you there's no risk of injury I'm
nursing a sore hammy I can't practice
can I go in and get that virtual rep
that's a phenomenal use case could we
prevent further injury absolutely how do
we get in front of NFL teams college
teams and then eventually bring the
learnings from working with those
customers down to the high school and
even middle school level the first NFL
team that we met with the Dallas Cowboys
said yes within two weeks
Clemson Stanford Arkansas Auburn temple
Vanderbilt and working with 20 teams you
know seven in the NFL 13 in college this
is gonna help our student-athletes be
better players how do you go from a
novice to an expert you know it's they
say ten years ten thousand hours well we
don't have ten years in college football
and we certainly don't have ten thousand
hours with the limits that we have but
in a ten minute session a player can get
a thousand reps if they want to and so
we have kids come in here every night
and they work and they get ahead in
football we train our feet we train our
bodies but there's it's so hard to train
people's eyes and that's really where
that's really where spores play it's you
know it's your reflexes it's what you
see it's your you know your your visual
capacities this will train that without
having to hit in 50 years it's easier to
imagine that a huge part of an athlete's
time will be spent in these sorts of
immersive environments the possible
safety benefits and hopefully cheaper
technology in the future you're gonna
see in a lot more places even if teams
don't necessarily totally buy into it
they're going to say hey wait a minute
my rivals have this I want it right now
in terms of this
says you put on the headset that's
visual it's audio you don't get hit but
down the road that stuff will probably
come about and it'll give people a
chance to feel what it's like to be an
NFL player the fan experience I think is
gonna completely change because of this
technology I think you'll see this in
everything because there's no sport that
you can play where you don't have to
have great eyes and we're just hitting
it you know the tip of the iceberg you
can see a few generations ahead anything
we do with any sort of educational bent
any sort of entertainment consumption
then everything is gonna be effective
this is the next platform